dans cet hôpital de cramât torse qu'une
seule spécialité médicale est encore en
place la traumatologie ces patients
attendent d'être stabilisée avant d'être
déplacé vers l'ouest comme yaacov blessé
par des éclats d'obus
ma femme est morte mon fils est en
territoire occupé à crémines à
je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer
ensuite
de nombreux médecins sont partis et des
volontaires venus d'autres villes
ukrainiennes les remplacent la plupart
sont spécialisés dans les blessures
crâniennes
les débris d'obus viennent d'enrôler
militaires ont un casque cela les
protège en quelque sorte
mais pour les civils ils ont très peu de
chances
malgré les risques ceux ci il s'engage
et apprennent à se protéger notamment
grâce aux gestes de premiers secours en
zones de guerre
si la blessure se situe au niveau du
bras on ne peut pas savoir exactement où
ça fait le plus mal donc vous posez le
tournis qu'est le plus haut possible sur
le bras gauche pour ces volontaires se
disent prêts à aller au front
je tiens ma vie et c'est ma mère patrie
ne
veut pas de ces partis
d'autres choisissent d'aidé sur le plan
humanitaire comme natalia qui coordonne
à la fois l'aide et des évacuations de
civils du moins quand cela est possible
croce ils ne veulent pas évacués ils ne
veulent pas ils ont peur ils ne veulent
pas vivre dans ces conditions
ils s'imaginent qu'ils vont partir et
que les appartements vont être
cambriolée
à ben arous les bombardements
s'intensifient depuis la chute de la
ville de lys chance qu'à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres de là si
certains civils décide de rester
d'autres n'ont tout simplement pas le
choix
maman lève toi s'il te plaît
la mère de valérie est handicapé
qu'est-ce que je peux faire qu'est ce
qu'elle peut faire ou pouvons-nous nous
enfuir monfils qu'est ce qui te
préoccupe
laisse tomber c'est juste à propos de
toi
qu'est ce que je peux dire
comment je peux attirer l'attention sur
ce qui se passe ici est d'aider
l'ukraine
bart monde fait partie de ces prochaines
villes clés dans le viseur de forces
russes l'arménie chrétienne se concentre
alors sur la défense de la province de
deux minutes